What Causes Dark Circles Under Your Eyes
It is often claimed that periorbital dark
circles are caused by tiredness or working
too hard or even just staying up late.
While this can be true, the truth is that
your genes play a huge role here.
So what exactly is happening when you get
dark circles under or around your eyes?
Simply put, periorbital dark circles are a
result of the thin layer of skin below your
eyes showing the blood vessels and the blood
they contain more clearly than anywhere else
on your body.
(For reference, this skin around your eyelids,
called periorbital skin, is on average about
0.5 mm thick compared to an average of about
2 mm thick on most of the rest of your body.)
Now, as you may or may not already know, the
reason veins often look blue isn’t because
the blood inside them is blue; it’s because
your skin/subcutaneous tissue only lets blue/violet
wavelengths of light pass through it.
As a result, only blue light is reflected
back and the veins look, well, bluish.
(Veins often won’t appear blue if a person
has darker or lighter skin.
Rather, the veins tend to appear green or
brown.
On the other hand, people with extremely light
skin, such as albinos, will typically have
veins that show up as dark purple or dark
red, more closely resembling the actual color
of the blood running through the veins.)
It’s the exact same concept with the skin
below your eyes.
Those dark bluish circles are (usually) just
the result of light being reflected back off
of the blood vessels sitting just below the
surface of that incredibly thin patch of skin.
This is the same reason facial bruises are
more prominent below or around the eyes; the
thin skin just shows the blood from the ruptured
blood vessels a little bit more clearly.
Again, as you may or may not know, as we age,
our skin loses its elasticity and ability
to regenerate and as a result, it becomes
thinner.
This is why more often than not, elderly people
will have rather prominent periorbital dark
circles regardless of how much they sleep.
As with those who are genetically predisposed
to having thinner skin below the eyes, it’s
just biology.
Another thing that can cause dark circles
beneath the eyes is something known as periorbital
hyperpigmentation, which is basically a condition
that results in more melanin being produced
by the skin below the eyes, resulting in it
appearing to be a darker color.
This is mostly a condition that affects (or
is at least more noticeable in) darker skinned
people.
According to Pratik B Sheth et al. of the
PDU Government Medical College and Hospital
in India, this is one of the most common complaints
dermatologists have to deal with.
Unfortunately, as explained in this case study
about an Indian gentleman with a particularly
severe case of periorbital melanosis, it’s
very difficult to treat in darker skinned
patients, which has led to a booming niche
market of cover up make-up for people with
darker complexions.
All that said, there are a number of factors
that can make dark circles appear worse, even
if you’re not genetically predisposed to
them.
One of the more serious sounding is the oxidisation
of blood leaking from the periorbital blood
vessels, which is just a fancier way of saying
that sometimes the blood vessels around your
eyes can get damaged, blood leaks out, and
you’re left with puffy dark circles under
your eyes.
It’s a relatively harmless problem and even
the chronic sufferers of this sort of blood
leaking need not worry too much about it.
It is also technically reversible with the
right treatment, though changes in lifestyle
are often recommended before one should consider
opting for surgery.
Another problem that goes hand-in-hand with
periorbital dark circles is periorbital puffiness,
a.k.a. bags below your eyes.
In young folk, this is almost always caused
by fluid buildup below the eyes, either due
to illness, allergies or simply excessive
salt consumption which can result in the body
retaining more fluid than usual.
This can place increased pressure on the skin
and blood vessels around the eyes which can
force blood vessels closer to the surface
of the skin, making dark circles appear more
prominent.
Eye puffiness can also simply be a result
of old age.
Now all of that is (hopefully) interesting
to you, but we still haven’t specifically
answered the question: Can those dark circles
be caused by fatigue and, if so, why?
Well the answer to the former is: sometimes.
So why exactly is this the case?
It’s not like lack of sleep makes your skin
thinner, right?
The answer is thought to lie in how the body
acts when it’s low on energy.
When the body is tired, production of the
chemical cortisol is dramatically increased
to help give you the energy you need to stay
awake.
Among many other things, cortisol actually
increases the volume of the blood in your
body, which causes the blood vessels (including
the ones below your eyes) to engorge to accommodate
it.
As we’ve already mentioned, dark circles
are mostly caused by us seeing our blood vessels
/ blood through our skin, so it stands to
reason that when those blood vessels are engorged,
they’d be easier to see, even in people
who may have been blessed with thicker skin
below their eyes.
So, whether by passing on their genes to you
or for not letting you sleep in after a gaming
all-nighter when you’re young, it’s all
your parent’s fault.
😉 Something that is/was even more reckless
of them as cortisol promotes fat accumulation.
So your lack of sleep is likely contributing
to more than just under-eye cosmetic issues.